joining us here is one of our favorites
fresh off fresh off of a win in
philadelphia where his brother plays
football and joining us a day before his
birthday
is none other than pro bowler
uh travis kelsey of the kansas city
chiefs here on the rich show how are you
travis
rich you know everything man how do you
know my birthday well
uh travis i i i i have a good day you
remember when i was born uh you know
what i was there and oh boy it was
incredible was that your breasts travis
i don't know if you're aware of that
dad
i don't know if you're aware of that
back in the day hey so uh listen uh what
was it like this weekend uh with your
your brother in philadelphia the kelsey
palooza a lot of people kind of missed
about all that how was that for you
man it was so much fun um i was
fortunate enough to go and see my my
brother my mom dad
we had a good um retirement party for my
mom 45 plus years in the banking world
and uh she finally
uh hung the hung the boots up and uh is
happily retired and i'm so happy for her
to you know
join that
that uh
that new part of life and um
outside of that you know just uh
getting another win 3-0 against jason
when do you when do you break that out
that information out like when when does
that card ever get played by travis on
jason kelsey
travis you know what it says it'll
probably be instinctual i don't know i
don't know when it will come come into
play maybe a couple years down the line
when we're both done playing uh football
um just to give a nice r reminder that
uh
he never beat the kansas city chief okay
that's good because you know i'm barring
a super bowl appearance uh with uh one
against the other it'll be another four
years till till you guys
have at it and um here's here's just one
thing i'm just throwing this out here
because you know uh the popularity of
the manning cast that's going on right
now i think they're off this week uh
peyton and eli for their monday night
football games a lot of people are
wondering who could do that
what what about a kelsey cast that is
something i would watch
travis man i am what do you think about
it jason is if he ever actually wanted
to get into anything on camera i think
he would kill it he would absolutely
absolutely kill it and i don't know
what's next for him once football is
over uh or myself in that that regard
but i think uh i think we would have a
whole lot of fun with it that's for sure
there's been plenty of um
those conversations going on just as we
sit down and watch you know
football throughout our years so i think
it would be very natural uh and it's
definitely i mean i don't know if we
could do it better than manning they're
they're i mean they're pretty dang on
entertaining if you ask me i've been
enjoying uh every monday night since
they've been on yeah i know and then i
the thing that i really enjoy is like
you know uh bad football they just can't
handle it they don't like they can't
take it they they just
or or just you know uh decisions that
are head scratchers is that what it's
like when you and your brother are
watching football
too um is that what that's like more so
it's more so point out the silly stuff
and uh and i mean if you if you see
something i'm not i'm not a downer i'm
not going to tell anybody they're scrub
um you know i'm telling you might have
to play a little better next time i'd
have to you know figure it out a
different way um but i'm never just
going to call out and say something's
bad ball uh you just got to be better
man i think i think that's kind of along
the lines that we would go but jason
jason's uh he's not shy to say to call
it how he is how it is so he might be
more of like peyton and eli in that
regard travis kelsey here on the rich
eisen show it was your third year in the
league uh 2015 the last time the chiefs
took the field as a sub 500 team as you
did
sunday in philadelphia um how how did
you guys
uh handle the week of i'm sure you know
everybody says that they try to keep the
negativity out
of the building but the conversation of
well maybe the chiefs have have been
figured out maybe this is a team that is
ripe for finally being taken down in the
afc after winning the conference the
last two years how did that conversation
sit from the outside world in your
building travis yeah i think um for the
most part we we have a great leadership
you know and starts
with coach reid um presenting us with a
challenge on tuesday to make sure that
we're all focused and we're not you know
falling astray we're we're staying
locked in with the goal at hand and and
this week this past week was the
philadelphia eagles and finding a way to
you know
make ourselves uh come out with a win on
sunday and it's just throughout the the
work week and i think uh you know a lot
of guys that matters to them in the
building and that's that's the biggest
thing is that you if when you got the
guys where that it matters to them they
want to come in and and fix the problems
um
it keeps a good momentum it keeps it
keeps a good chemistry going on in the
building that we're just keep that that
we're working towards a goal at hand and
um that's all we did and then sure
enough we practiced our tails off uh
last week i felt like probably two or
three training camp practices i mean i
was out there drenched in sweat just
trying to get the work in and i know
everybody else was and um that's just
the mentality that you have to have you
can't you can't panic you can't let
things you know uh get out of hand you
have to make sure that you know and and
plus if you look at the film the first
couple weeks it was all
it was a lot of mistakes done by done by
us you know teams i mean granted hats
off to
baltimore and los angeles for getting
the wins i mean i'm not going to take
any
anything away from that but there was
turnovers right and then and then little
stuff like drop passes and um not
getting opening routes so things that we
could clean up that could help us win
is uh where the deciding factors in my
mind well again i know you're not in
their meeting rooms but they are your
teammates the the defense in particular
has been the ones
it's not just the turnovers of those two
losses it was the defense being
susceptible how how have they handled
the challenge
um so far on that front
travis i mean they're just coming
they're fighting they're fighting it's
not it's not effort we i mean
the teams we played have had good
schemes and we got to find ways to to
make the big plays when when the
opportunity presents itself and i know
those guys are going to keep fighting
they're going to keep figuring things
out spags is
over the years has been known for
gradually getting better throughout the
season um
understanding his pieces more and more
and i'm sure that you know we have great
leadership like i said both on offense
and defense and just in the building so
i know things are gonna you know keep
getting better on both sides of the ball
uh knowing that you know we weren't
perfect uh as offense this sunday either
travis kelsey three-time all-pro tight
end right here on the rich eisen show
mercedes-benz vans hotline um how how's
coach how's he doing i mean what can you
tell me fired up man he just became the
first coach in nfl history to get a
hundred wins for two two franchises
right and that's uh that's a feat that i
mean i don't know i can barely even
fathom that man he's just uh he's good
though health health-wise he came into
the building like i said on tuesday and
presented us with a challenge and let
everybody know that um he was doing just
fine and things were back to normal what
do you mean he presented you with where
we're at what do you mean he presented
you with the challenge what did he say
what can you tell me so when every every
single week uh we have a new challenge
at stake a new team um he watches the
film from last week uh some sort of
review he'll talk to us about review of
last week and then he'll talk to us
where we're going moving forward and how
we're going to attack the team that we
have uh coming up okay team coming up
the buffalo bills you know they're
they're they're definitely gunning for
you and that's a very famous photograph
from last year's
afc championship game post game
celebration for you with stefan diggs
standing on the
on the field there i don't know if you
saw that photograph he was standing on
the field there watching you guys
celebrate
so
you know they're bawling that thing up
ready to come hit you in week number
five in front of the whole country
sunday night so what's your two cents on
that defense that seems to be uh boat
racing opponents right now travis yeah i
mean well they're playing they're
playing pretty stellar lights out right
now on offense um over there in buffalo
uh stefan d i mean i can put myself in
those shoes
losing an afc championship game um it's
that's not easy stuff to see someone
else get a trip to the super bowl i've
been in those shoes before and i know
how motivated it can make you so
we know we're going to get the best
their best shot i mean there's a great
football team and i think uh sunday
night's gonna be one heck of a fight
it's gonna be i know that man no
question i can't i i'm looking forward
to seeing that did you watch
last night's were you home in time to
watch brady and belichick go against
each other which literally i was i was
and honestly it was it was it was pretty
entertaining to see him duke it out and
then of course it had to be new england
weather
um right on the spot and make it even
more intriguing game
and uh i think that um that's that's
what it's all about is you know
finding ways to to win in those tough
situations like uh like tom brady did
last night so did you i don't know why
but i i was kind of rooting for tom last
night i don't know i don't know what it
was around i don't know why i think it
was just like uh
i i don't know i was more i was more
intrigued in seeing him when than uh
than belichick he said you know it's
called stockholm syndrome when you root
for your captors travis that's sort of
that's that you know to get to
you know deep on your syndrome
you know
diagnosing me with these things you know
i think that's what that sounds like but
i'm i'm wondering why like i feel like
this is like a you know a therapy
session why why were you rooting for for
tom over over the patriots do you think
travis um honestly i think uh i think
it's more so because of uh the
experiences my family's had with the new
england fans so that i just have a new
england's a dark place in my mind
so i don't know and and it's not to say
anything about the the players over
there because i actually hunter henry um
johnny smith i mean you name it those
guys mac jones three great guys right
there that i
root for um but there's something about
the the patriots it's just gloomy and
i don't know i hear you um and so uh
what did you see just uh you know before
i let you go here what what we what did
you see that
that belichick and the defense was
dialing up travis did you see anything
when you're watching did you see
what was potentially giving tom fitz in
a way because i that was phenom i mean
the thing i was really you know taken
aback by is obviously the conversations
that you have with your coaches and that
what patrick mahomes must have with reed
you know everybody knows each other you
know each other you know your life you
know your dislikes i cannot imagine what
20 years of those conversations between
belichick and brady was like and that
could be a rolodex for
bill to to try and create a a game plan
against tom i'm wondering what you
a uh a top-notch player in nfl history
which you are would think about watching
stuff like that that's what made it fun
that's what made it fun to watch it was
like we were
watching the ultimate chess match
whenever the the bucks were on the field
and um it was it was like we were we
were watching just two guys go at it
wasn't like it was like a an 11 on 11
game you know and that i just think that
was kind of a cool aspect of football i
don't
think that anyone's ever had this this
type of opportunity uh 20 years later to
play against their their old coach and
uh especially for winning as many
championships as they did and all the
success that they had so i think it's um
without a doubt a very unique situation
that uh it kind of made the game feel a
little bit different than it usually
does how's the group how's the beard
growing back most importantly travis are
you growing it back no i'm keeping it
i'm keeping it right at like uh
five o'clock to eight o'clock shadow
right now okay um still still see a
little bit of that
the cheek and the chin okay um but you
know not looking uh
just you know like a thumb out here
what's what's
[Laughter]
what's the game plan though is there a
long-term plan or is this just a
day-to-day week
right here at about a half
not a one not a two but a half okay
right here got it and uh and ride it out
and
um yeah we'll see what happens as it
gets colder out okay we'll we'll keep an
eye on all that and uh again my my two
sons xander and cooper uh owners of the
joey special and
um the uh two kelsey for comfort are
rooting for you you you are the featured
uh uh player on both their fantasy teams
travis so
your name is i'll pick up my slack this
week no
it's okay travis you can't i mean travis
you know you know obviously tyreek had
the week oh and i guess last one for you
the word is that josh gordon looks so
terrific we might actually see him
shortly for the chiefs how does he look
to you travis kelsey man he looks
he looks athletic fast strong i mean
everything that you can imagine him uh
in being when he walked in he came in in
shape
last week i know the coaches uh
mike kafka our our quarterback coach was
really working on him on certain routes
to make sure he understands the offense
a little bit better in the timing of it
and um i mean when he runs routes man
it's like
i don't i don't know what i want i'm
watching something i've never seen
before it's like poetry in motion man
he's uh he's such a fluent athlete and
um he's just came in with the right
mentality it's fun it's fun having him
in the building and hopefully we can uh
use his abilities sooner than later so
he didn't he he didn't you know come in
with all the honey buns is what you're
saying he's he's he's rocked up oh man
just a hard-working hard-working fun guy
he's having fun in the locker room uh
jailing with everybody okay and uh yeah
i don't see it going any other way man
oh man
that would be an addition let's just put
it that way that's just one way to put
it that would be quite something he
shows up and and you know he's one to
root for obviously you know he's
exciting exactly you know so i
appreciate the time thanks very much uh
travis always great to catch up with you
really appreciate it as always rich you
know it right back at you i do not take
it for granted that's travis kelsey
calling in after a win in philadelphia
kelsey palooza mom had a retirement
party he's got the win back to 500
didn't even mention that in my fourth
down last week i said the chiefs lose
only one more game rest of the year
one for one one for one for one 12 more
to go hey you watched all the way to the
end thanks for that watch more right
here